so everyone I knew that in making videos
about the meaning in movies eventually
someone would ask me if I was going to
do something on Star Wars and I mean I
grew up with Star Wars just like most of
you listen to this and though I've never
been a crazy fan I like Star Wars and I
even like these the two last movies that
came out I've got a serious beef let's
call it a symbolic beef with Star Wars
if such a thing exists and it's it's a
problem I have with the basic premise of
Star Wars and maybe it's something that
that some of you can help me figure out
maybe you can help me get through this
I mean what's funny is that the Star
Wars movies are is probably the Star
Wars movies probably the first movie
that started the more mythological trend
in movies in their interpretation and in
their production through a discussion
with Joseph Campbell but I think Star
Wars gets something wrong or at least
it's confused and maybe that shows you
what I really think of Joseph Campbell
so but they get wrong I think is the
whole idea of the light side and the
dark side of the force
I mean I get it you know it's a it's a
post Second World War movie there's bad
Nazi totalitarians
you know dark side of the force and then
there's good rebellious alliance trying
to restore democracy light side of the
force and like I said I get it but still
something just isn't right I mean if you
think about it in terms of symbolism why
is an empire with power over all the
galaxies using the dark side of the
force I mean why does the emperor of an
immense Empire wear a black hooded cloak
why would I never have to hide like that
he looks like a necromancer who raises
zombies in some underground crypts
somewhere the symbols of emperors have
always been solar Roman emperors were
often shown with or as Sol Invictus the
invincible Sun
Emperor's were shown as being chosen by
Christ covered in gold and jewels I mean
all these images of light in order mean
that's the point an empire is order
institutions hierarchy a public
structure with public figures its rebels
that have to hide have to be further
than tricky you know smuggle rebels have
to conceal themselves in darkness think
of ninjas think of the Shiite assassins
no a movie like Batman Begins gets it
right that the Batman Begins they have
this League of Shadows right there's the
dark side it's a secret organization
with the goal of undermining and
destroying great civilizations and
empires when they get corrupt I mean
that's the dark side large battalions of
super logistics with immense
triangle-shaped ships mean that screams
too much order too much like too much
clarity I mean even in the contemporary
parody which was the Trump election
these alt-right types they they portray
them as a solar figure goddamn for Trump
right I mean it's an Tifa that has to
hide their faces dress in black black is
the color of protest not the color of
empire empires project gleaming light as
they're like Matisse so it just doesn't
make sense to me in Star Wars you think
of it even at a personal level they to
try to get Luke to join him by telling
him that he's his father that that makes
sense then the emperor tells Luke to
give in to his emotion to give in his
rage and his resentment and kill his
father me give in to your raw chaotic
emotion given to your passions and then
join the biggest military techno
bureaucratic state one can imagine and
rule the entire galaxy it's not like
Luke would be joining a street gang
where he has to kill someone as it
creation so we can then rob people beat
people up and sell dope mean it's an
Galactic Empire Kara's groups get people
to indulge in their darker passions so
then they so that they can then feel
guilty enough that they're willing to
blow themselves up and make them take as
many people with them I mean school
shooters are the one who give in to
their rage and resentment not the number
two men in a Galactic Empire I mean even
if that Galactic Empire is tyrannical
and evil and by the way there is such a
thing as an excess of light light is not
always good for us mortals there is such
a thing as an excess of order an excess
of rigor and it's usually portrayed as
fire or destructive light there is such
a thing as the wrath of heaven you know
we we have this kind of campy cliche
form in our imagination of the angry god
who throwing lightning bolts to judge
and destroy something I mean there's
Elijah who brings fire from heaven we
have st. Michael who comes down from
heaven with a lance to pierce the Dark
One's this idea of a lance or a bolt of
lightning he doesn't that remind you of
something something in Star Wars and
sometimes it's image of the king with
the land I mean it can become tyrannical
and evil I mean there's this example in
the Bible the future King David hid in a
cave and associated with an army of
riffraff and criminals while King Saul
kept wanting to Pierce to David with a
lance and during that time King David
associated with the enemies of Israel
acted like a madman even engage in what
should have been considered sacrilege by
eating the showbread that was in the
tabernacle and so and it's not like
there aren't there is never a time for
subversive or dark tactics you look at
Batman The Dark Knight
I mean what he does is fueled by his
anger and despair at losing his parents
but then he goes around and beats up
thugs
he doesn't
rule the world that's the dark side of
the course
anger and anger and injustice can be the
fuel used to resist a tyrannical emperor
who tries to push on us excessive light
tries to pry open all our private
conversation and thoughts so that he can
control them so I'm sorry in the end it
just seems like Star Wars gets it wrong
at a very basic level and I keep
wondering if that's not part of the
confusion of the world is slipping and
today so that's my idea tell me what you
think I mean convince me I'm wrong in
the comments and I'll engage with you
thanks a lot